economía me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañero jorge hurtado jorge comenzamos
hablando del retiro de las tropas de
afganistán que tuvieron lugar en ese
país y ya se habla de una crisis
alimentaria en esa nación asiática bueno
un mes después definitivamente según la
oficina de alimentos de naciones unidas
4 millones de afganos se enfrentan a una
emergencia alimentaria la mayoría de
ellos provienen de zonas rurales la fao
seguro que se necesitan con urgencia 36
millones de dólares para garantizar la
siembra de trigo de invierno y dar
asistencia en efectivo para familias
vulnerables escuchamos bien millones de
afganos rurales dependen de la
agricultura para su alimentación y sus
ingresos la agricultura representa algo
más del 25 por ciento del producto
interno bruto del país emplea
directamente alrededor del 45 por ciento
de la fuerza laboral de la nación
y quizás lo más importante proporciona
beneficios para el sustento de un 80 por
ciento de la población afgana esas
cifras por sí solas le dicen cuán
indispensable es la agricultura en el
contexto de afganistán
bueno la calificadora fitch estima que
la economía de afganistán que es
dependiente de la ayuda internacional se
va a contraer 97 por ciento de este año
y por lo menos un 52 % en 2022 aumente
la llegada al poder de los talibanes la
crisis económica se agrava mientras las
opciones son pocas debido a la falta de
apoyo internacional hay reacciones en
españa' al incremento de la factura de
energía que lo que pasa con el precio de
electricidad continúa experimentando
aumentos históricos en españa' mientras
el gobierno toma medidas para enfrentar
el alza este jueves el precio llegará a
188 euros el megavatio ahora el alta de
precio del gas natural en los mercados
internacionales está beneficiando a los
productores de gas y a las empresas
energéticas que generan energía a partir
de otras fuentes entre las medidas
aprobadas más importantes está la
creación de un suministro mínimo vital
para las personas de escasos recursos y
la confiscación de una buena parte de
los beneficios de las empresas de
energía las acciones de las empresas del
sector se desplomaron en la bolsa
española como consecuencia de este
anuncio el alza no solamente afecta a
europa no solamente afecta a españa sino
también a toda europa porque hablemos
ahora de canadá donde no hay una buena
proyección económica para este país
norteamericano bueno la inflación se
disparó ahí un 4,1 por ciento en agosto
y es la más elevada desde 2003 en canadá
esta alza es producto del aumento en los
precios de la gasolina y la vivienda los
datos fueron presentados por el centro
de estadísticas de canadá este es el
quinto mes consecutivo que la inflación
supera proyecciones del banco de canadá
aunque la autoridad monetaria canadiense
asegura que esta inflación de la
economía es temporal y que espera que la
situación se normaliza en 2022 los datos
llegan cinco días antes de que los
canadienses acudan a las urnas para
elegir a un nuevo gobierno
hablemos ahora de centroamérica que
celebra su bicentenario cuéntanos cómo
está la economía de la región de su país
así es bueno un estudio de la comisión
económica para américa latina y el
caribe cepal indica que la economía
centroamericana crecerá un 5,5 por
ciento de 2021
este crecimiento económico es liderado
por panamá y el salvador según la cepal
el salvador sería la segunda economía de
centroamérica que más crecería en 2021
tras un 12 por ciento previsto para
panamá para el resto de los países
santiago se espera un repunte de 4.6 por
ciento del producto interno bruto en
guatemala 5 por ciento para honduras
mientras que costa rica crecería 3.7 por
ciento y nicaragua un 2.5 por ciento
pese a ello la pandemia provocó una
fuerte caída de ingresos en las mipymes
de centroamérica una investigación del
centro para la promoción de la micro y
pequeña empresa indica que el 64.7 por
ciento de las empresas encuestadas
redujo sus ventas en 2020 y otros 19,3
por ciento consiguió mantener la acción
16% logró aumentar sus ventas hablemos
ahora de los indicadores como las balas
bolsas bueno wall street cerró positivo
por el entusiasmo de los inversores y
sus expectativas de un desarrollo
económico futuro y en américa latina'
también hubo números rojos en brasil la
bolsa cayó luego de que se conocieran
las bajas proyecciones para el próximo
año
y la cifra del día la cifra del día es
89 mil millones de dólares es la deuda
del gigante inmobiliario chino ever
great con los bancos si esta empresa
quiebra podría sacudir los mercados
financieros globales aunque analistas
dicen que es probable que pekín
intervenga para evitarlo pues muy atento
a lo que sucede allí muchas gracias
jorge por esta información actualización
del mundo económico estado por el
momento aquí en france 24 siga con
nosotros buenas noches
[Música]